-Gamins de merde, là
-Coucou ! Mon chéri !
-Ah... Maman, ça va ?
-Hum, ça sent le cannabis, non?
- Ah ouais t'as raison ouais. Ouais les gamins commencent super tôt, hein
- Gaëtan...
Je suis contente que tu sois là.
-Ah ouais euh tu m'as vraiment laissé le choix hein super
Tu sais que c'est une mauvaise idée là... J'aime pas les gamins...
-Arrête, ça va très bien se passer, ils sont adorables mes élèves.
Essaie juste une fois, pour voir.
Hé, je t'ai pas payé une école de dessin à 5000 euros par an pour rien.
-Une école de dessin ???
Ah oui l'école de dessin, ouais ouais...
-Voilà, tu leur montre tes trucs de dessin, c'est simple...
Par contre, si jamais ils te demandent
de faire des bonhommes, tu dis non. Pas de bonhomme. C'est trop simple.
Gaëtan... Je t'aime.
-Salut...
-Salut.
-Je suis le remplaçant de madame Brodier... Parce que elle est malade,
elle a euh... la chiasse. - Génial...
Elle reviendra quand? -Elle va revenir la prochaine
fois. Toute façon je vais pas rester donner des cours à des morveux hein...
-Vous voulez voir nos dessins ? -Non, non, ça m'intéresse pas.
-Ah vous savez quoi? Montrez moi vos dessins. On va perdre du temps comme ça
c'est très bien... Mouais... Super moche, d'accord... Nul
Pas beau... Pourri, ouais ça dégage... Waouh t'asa fait ça
tout seul, sans rire, c'est nul, t'as quel âge ? T'as 10 ans? -Oui.
-Il vous plaît mon dessin?
-Ah ouais c'est super ! Non mais c'est pas toi qui as fait ça, c'est tes parents c'est pas possible... -Si, si, c'est moi.
Et vous, vous nous montrez vos dessins ?
-Ah nan mais moi j'ai...
Moi j'ai pas mes dessins avec moi... Mais toute façon c'est comme... c'est comme
ça là mais en... Ouais en  mieux... Ouais, les proportions elles sont un peu claquées han...
Euh alors on va commencer le cours...
-On peut dessiner des bonhommes ??
-Non. (contestation générale)
Aujourd'hui, on va voir...
Ouais voilà, donc le cours d'aujourd'hui euh...
ça va être sur la perspective... -Mais monsieur, on l'a déjà fait
Ouais, ouais, ouais... Et ben on va faire euh.. le fusain ? -Ça aussi !
-Les couleurs primaires? -On a vu ça la semaine dernière
-Et bah on va faire des bonhommes.
(cris de joie)
-On dessine qui comme bonhomme?
-Bah je sais pas moi tu dessines un bonhomme. Tu fais un...
(bruits d'éclairs)
De-Dessinez des... trucs, je reviens
(un vaisseau apparaît)
(Bruits du vaisseau qui se pose)
Vous inquiétez pas les enfants hein
Y a aucun problème...
(cris de panique)
-Il veut qu'on le dessine? -J'en sais rien moi, je sais pas !
Ok, ok les enfants
on va dessiner le bonhomme devant nous ok ? Et on lui montre le plus beau dessin !
-Mais monsieur, c'est vous qui dessinez le mieux. -Je... je.. Bah
tout le monde participe ! On prend une feuille, un crayon et on va dessiner...
Allez, allez ! Les feutres
(MUSIQUE STRESSANTE)
-C'est vraiment de la merde, putain...
-Ah j'ai plus d'encre dans mon feutre, donc euh... dommage... -Vous voulez
que je vous prête un feutre? -Non mais y a plus de feutres... euh il y a plus le temps donc euh... Le monsieur s'impatiente
montrez moi vos dessins.
Montrez moi les dessins allez !!! Ouais.. ça c'est nul...c'est nul...
ça a pas évolué, c'est dégueulasse...c'est dégueulasse
OK, donc toi t'as même pas compris ce qu'il fallait faire...
ON VA CREVER ! -Pardon... Pousse toi !
-Il vous plaît mon dessin ?
-Oh il est super ! Enfin, y a des trucs à revoir mais c'est super ! On va ptêtre... On va ptêtre rester en vie.
-Je vais lui donner... - Non, non je lui donne moi, t'inquiéte pas.. -Non c'est moi ! -Non non t'inquiéte pas c'est moi...
-MAIS C'EST MON DESSIN C'EST MOI QUI LUI DONNE !
(cris de panique)
-Faites lui un dessin monsieur ! Non mais j'ai... j'ai pas de feutre  donc euh...
-Monsieur... Faut lui faire le plus beau dessin. -Oui bah je sais je sais !
-ALLEZ! - Oui bah je... T-t-tournez vous vous me déconcentrez là !
(musique stressante)
AAHHH!
(bruits de décollage)
-OUAIS!!!!! -Yes! - Monsieur vous êtes le meilleur ! -Vous êtes trop fort! -Il devait être super votre dessin !
- Il... Il  était bien... Il était super... - J'espère que vous reviendrez bientôt...
-YESS!!!
-OUAAAAAIIIIIS !!!
-Gaëtan?
Il se passe quoi là à l'école ?
-C'est long à expliquer, t'inquiète pas...
-Bon alors, comment ça s'est passé?
-Ça s'est bien passé... Et je crois qu'ils m'aiment bien.
-Tu vois, c'était pas la mort.
-Tu l'aimes bien la petite Léa ? -Ah, m'en parle pas...
Elle est douée hein...
Mais alors quelle peste... Et collante...
Toujours des questions nianiania... Madame!
Madame! nianiania
-Tu crois que je pourrais redonner des cours ?
-Bah oui super !
Faut que je voies... Faut que je demandes à la directrice.
-Maman, tu crois aux extraterrestres?
-Gaëtan...
Faut que t'arrêtes de fumer...
Merci d'avoir regardé mon court métrage,  n'hésitez pas à cliquer juste en dessous, là
pour découvrir le making of, voir comment on a fait les effets spéciaux, comment on a fait l'alien...
Comment s'est passé le tournage... et n'hésitez pas à vous abonner
Vous êtes 12 millions ça me fait très plaisir, peut être 13 un jour, je ne sais pas, à bientôt ! :D
Sous-titres: Aure-Anne B, Noémie Lesne, vms, OKIÑO, Ecko, Marion!